hey happy monday to you people i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's october 25th in the year
as always you can chat live with other
viewers right this moment go to
reubenreport.locals.com or download the
locals ios or android app you can chat
i've got my assistant helen in there she
can get messages to us on the fly as i'm
doing the show so if i get anything
wrong you can let me know you can fact
check me you can ask me a question if
you have a particularly pithy or
insightful comment i might read it live
on the show that is just one of the many
ways we are now including you in what we
do here and it is just the beginning on
that front and with that in mind you
know i've been teasing for a while that
we would have a a pretty freaking major
announcement coming
tomorrow
it's finally coming tomorrow i wanted it
to happen last week it looked like maybe
it could happen last week then i thought
it could happen friday some stuff happen
can't get into all the nitty-gritty of
why it didn't exactly happen but 100
i dave rubin promised you that a major
announcement that is not only related to
what i do here and this show
but much more than that
ah that's all i can say now i want to
say more but just think i think if
you've been watching me for a while and
especially if you've been playing along
in the ruben report community i've been
trying to hint at things enough
and uh let's just say
hope
is coming all right how about we leave
it at that uh we got three stories for
you today but it's a jam-packed show
because each story has a whole bunch of
stuff attached to it video and text
today uh lots of nuttiness over the
weekend we're gonna start with a couple
coved things uh first off the story that
really is getting everybody right now i
think it's maybe the number one trend on
twitter at the moment is that it turns
out that fauci was funding some really
really perverse
uh studies and experiments with dogs
with uh beagle puppies where they were
literally trapping them and putting
their heads i mean we're gonna show you
an image and i i warn you it's quite
disgusting we're only going to show you
one image if you have to look away when
we do so be it
but where they were having basically
like bugs eat away their faces while
they wouldn't let any of the rest of
their body do anything about it he was
funding this why exactly we'll find out
and of course that now he's been really
caught in a lie which i've talked about
with rand paul and everyone sort of knew
was a lie that the nih was basically
funding gain of function research that's
now
pretty much come out fully
and will he pay for lying to congress
probably not but either way we'll talk
about it uh then this barack obama guy
remember barack obama ran the country
for eight years didn't do anything about
systemic racism didn't fix anything so
then we had to get this old guy who
worked for him joe joe biden to be uh
president um well he's back and he's
getting involved now in the virginia
gubernatorial race and he just gave a
speech that was just profoundly
disgusting and dishonest and i'll show
you a clip of that and then finally
we've got some stuff from biden himself
from crazy kamala and janet yellen the
treasury secretary who wants to tax
money that you don't have yeah that's
the new thing we're gonna tax future
money
because the government really really
needs more of your money but before i do
any of those stories i wanted to tell
you quickly
about friday night because on friday
night i think we've got an image of it i
had dinner with that guy
yeah that is florida governor ron
desantis and i was at a fundraiser in
san francisco i went all the way up to
san francisco just for the night uh
david sacks who has been on the show
who's a huge vc guy runs craft ventures
one of the investors in locals
who also was part of the original paypal
mafia and he's sent a gajillion
companies into the stratosphere he held
a fundraiser at his house in san
francisco for ron desantis and it was
spectacular it really really was
spectacular ron spoke for or the
governor spoke for probably about 20
minutes maybe a half hour i'd say there
were 100 maybe 150 people there
something like that
and every single thing he said made
sense it was wild i was actually sort of
you know when you have those moments
when you're listening to someone talk or
you're watching a certain movie or
you're listening to a certain music and
you're like oh this is real this is true
this is relevant and honest that's what
it felt like listening to the guy he's
he's very natural speaker he's kind of
funny when he when he had to be
but talked about the right things
balancing
freedom with responsibility
talking about why the government
shouldn't be telling you what to do in
your life at all times how florida is
defending itself how their economy has
grown despite all this craziness how
they're bringing in more law enforcement
instead of defunding them all the
vaccine mandate stuff of course of
course
and it was just it was so refreshing
like it was generally genuinely like
the entire evening i was like i can't
believe this you know because here in
california where i am at least for now
it's like i'm pretty sure i'm on some
list from gavin newsom i'm on a not good
person list right like i tried to get
rid of that guy and and unfortunately
the brainwashed people of california
didn't agree
um but to see that there are governors
there are public officials who don't
want to just endlessly run your life it
was just an absolute absolute pleasure
and maybe in a couple of weeks i'll tell
you a bit more about my conversation
with
with governor desantis it was just it
was really great and uh you know when i
always talk about that hope thing it's
like there are glimmers of hope and and
even though the politicians aren't the
ones that can fully save us it's nice to
know that there are a couple of good
ones out there okay let's get to the
stories because there is a lot to talk
about today so first off uh fouchy
and this dog situation it's really just
ridiculous we are going to show you one
image i'm going to read a little bit
from the hill house members most of whom
are republicans want fauci to explain
himself in response to allegations
brought on by the white coat waste
project that involves drugging puppies
white coast waste claims that 44 beagle
puppies were used in a tunisia north
africa laboratory and some of the dogs
had their vocal cords removed alleging
so scientists could work without
incessant barking our investigators show
that fauci's nih division shipped part
of a 375
800 grant to a lab in tunisia to drug
beagles and lock their heads in mesh
cages with hungry sand flies so that the
insects could eat them alive white coast
weight told changing america they also
locked beagles alone in cages in the
desert overnight for nine consecutive
nights to use them as bait to attract
infectious sand flies so we're showing
you one image there i don't want to
berate
the point with the image
look scientists do all sorts of things
researchers do all sorts of stuff we do
things with monkeys we do things with
rabbits we do things
with bugs we do things we do all kinds
of stuff and i am not going to sit here
and pretend that i am perfectly versed
in every which way it is ethical and not
ethical uh to do certain experiments on
animals uh however
i will say this you guys know i'm a dog
guy
the idea that you would lock dogs just
put the picture up for one more second
what they're doing with this there are
sand flies in there those dogs are just
eating their faces off and they are
completely defenseless
to stop that from happening and they've
had their vocal cords cut because they
were barking because they didn't want
their faces
eaten off this is something that anthony
fauci
helped to fund now i don't know exactly
what it is what they thought that
experiment would prove and what that
what they would lead to
uh what that would lead to was okay
but the idea that they thought that was
okay and i have no doubt that if they're
doing that sort of thing they're
probably doing other things that are
unimaginably more horrible um these are
not good people like whatever they were
trying to prove there whatever it is
that they were trying to prove how long
could an animal exist while its face was
being eaten off if you cut off its
defenses whatever they were trying to
prove um perhaps there was another way
to prove it beyond taking beagle puppies
and having their faces eaten off but
fauci felt like that was okay and the
people around him felt like that was
okay and this is the guy that is in
charge apparently of our entire covent
policy now almost two years later to
flatten the curve
you have to think about that what you
will i just cannot see how that is a
decent human being i cannot see how that
is a decent human being let me pull a
picture of clyde now here's clyde on the
left as you know clyde is a rescue our
our dog emma had just passed away about
two months before lockdown and we
weren't going to get a dog again because
we were going to wait actually through
the summer because i was going to be
touring with don't burn this book
obviously the tour didn't happen because
of covid but either way we weren't going
to get a dog for a little bit and then
the day lockdown started i saw a story
how la shelters were going to put down
all of these dogs and i ran to our local
shelter and i saw clyde and he had a
they already had the paper signed he had
about an hour left before he was going
to be put down uh and you can see he had
a scar on his head which we've since
gotten him surgery to get rid of and we
saved clyde uh that's clyde on the right
just that's from a couple days ago uh
that's clyde living his best life and uh
my previous dog emma who most of you
know the story she was also a rescue
from hurricane katrina she gave birth to
puppies in a box during the hurricane
puppies were eventually
adopted it took her almost nine months
to be healthy enough to be adopted so i
we didn't even get her until june of
2006. anyway i mention all of this
because i'm the type of person that
saves dogs i like to save dogs i don't
like when i hear that people are buying
dogs or breeders or all that sort of
stuff there are so many thousands and
thousands
of dogs
that are
great and wonderful and need homes uh
fauci decided to put dogs heads in boxes
and have basically a flesh-eating bug
eat their faces off so i'm just just put
that like a little pin in your fouchy
thing you know like you're thinking oh
fouchy's so great voucher's such a good
man he's just a public servant is the
most highest paid person in the federal
government he's so great also funds bugs
eating dogs faces off but
nobody's nobody's perfect
but there's more fauci's in a lot of
trouble right now actually uh because as
you know i've had rand paul on the show
a couple of times and there's that very
famous moment when fauci's testifying
before congress and rand paul is saying
you guys the nih funded gain of function
research
in wuhan and fauci gets indignant you
don't know what you're talking about
blah blah blah well now we've got some
more info from the new york post the
national institutes of health has
stunningly admitted to funding gain of
function research bat coronaviruses at
china's wuhan lab despite dr anthony
fauci repeatedly insisting to congress
that no such thing happened in a letter
to representative james comer from
kentucky on wednesday a top nih official
blamed eco health alliance the new york
city-based non-profit that profit that
has funneled u.s funds to the wuhan lab
for not being transparent about the work
it was doing nih's principal deputy
director lawrence a tavik wrote in the
letter that ecohealth's limited
experiment tested weather spiked
proteins from naturally occurring bat
coronaviruses circulating in china were
capable of binding to the human ace2
receptor in a mouse model the admission
from the nih official directly
contradicts fauci's testimony to
congress in may and july when he denied
the u.s had funded gain of function
projects in wuhan okay
so here's where we're at with this thing
he either fauci either lied under oath
and said no we did not fund gain of
function research or he did not know
now
if he lied well if you lie under oath
congress i think you get in trouble is
that a thing do you get in trouble if
you like not always
he gave me the head nod you don't always
get in trouble that's right and i always
bring up uh
you know what was his name uh james
clapper uh who you know lied under oath
they asked him if uh you know the nsa
and the fbi uh
if we spy on our own citizens and he
goes not wittingly while he's scratching
his head well he became a cnn
contributor never got in trouble so
fatchi will probably get away with it
but either fauci lied under oath or he
did not know what the nih was doing
which as the director of the nih it
seems to me that the buck has to stop
with somebody so maybe he should step
down like this is
the type of scandal that should have
this ridiculous man step away like just
step away now fauci like this thing is
obviously not going well
you have emailed friends in the midst of
the pandemic at the height of it telling
friends that they don't have to wear
masks while you were telling the rest of
us to wear masks you told other people
that they shouldn't wear masks because
you actually touch your face more while
you were telling other people to double
mask
we're long gone from two weeks to
flatten the curve we're long gone from
hurt immunity you've made a complete
clown of yourself but i'll make you a
deal anthony fauci if you step away now
you got let's say this week i would say
by friday right because it takes a
couple days to clear out the office and
get the box and put all the picture
frames in there if you go by friday i'll
give you a pass going forward i won't
even mention you again like it'll be
like you know what at the end fauci was
a little over his head he probably
wasn't a horrific human being despite
having bugs that were eating dogs faces
off and i'll just let it slide i'll just
be like that's it we're not going to put
him in jail i don't think he should be
punished he just got caught up in
something and that's it so you got till
friday as far as i'm concerned about you
but you got to go because you're either
a lawyer a liar
you're a lawyer lawyer liar there you go
freudian slip of the day
you're either a liar
or you don't know what's going on at
your organization which thus caused you
to lie under oath
unwittingly so either way you gotta go
buddy uh but we've got more from fauci
because all he does is go on these
sunday talk shows he is more of a public
showman than he is a scientist at this
point and uh don't worry guys if you've
been freaking out about your little kids
that they haven't been injected yet
bouchie's on it so if all goes well and
we get the regulatory approval and the
recommendation from the cdc it's
entirely possible if not very likely
that vaccines will be available for
children from 5 to 11 within the first
week or two of november
okay so that's very very exciting
because it's obviously what he's wanted
all along it's what these people have
wanted along they want to vaccinate
everyone even children who are at
virtually no risk again
cdc website point zero zero two percent
of children under eighteen die of covid
yes some of them get sick and they get
healthier and then they have natural
immunity again he doesn't talk about
that anymore i i know people that are
our parents we're working on having kids
i've talked to a lot of people about
this i don't know anyone and i get it
it's self-selected because i usually am
friends with somewhat sane people these
days but i don't know anyone that wants
their five or six year olds getting
injected with this thing i get it there
are blue and on npc brainwashed cnn
watchers with their children that want
the government every week to just inject
their children with whatever they want
but there is virtually no risk to
children and not only is there virtually
no risk to children but we are to
believe that the teachers basically are
all vaccinated the parents are all
vaccinated in all of those things so
it's not like the kid that might get
sick is going to pass it on to the
teacher if vaccines work but could it
possibly be
guys help me with this one could it
possibly be that the vaccines aren't
working exactly as promised i don't want
to be a conspiracy theorist i don't want
to get deleted from youtube they told me
they were working perfectly
you see what i'm saying people you see
what i'm saying uh and if you don't
think all of this is weird enough that
now they want to come after your kids
and again
if you have a child that has some
pre-existing condition
or even not
go talk to your doctor don't listen to
that clown and don't listen to me talk
to your doctor and and read some of the
literature yourself it's readily
available and it's not that fun to read
but it is out there but if you don't
think they have a more nefarious plan in
mind well here's cdc director waleski
this woman is just a piece of work she's
got a plan
let's talk about mandates for adults the
president biden was asked about the
quite controversial mandates for
essential workers at his town hall this
week take a look at his answer
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be stay at home
or let go yes and yes
now mandates by government by private
companies have
of essential workers have generally work
you see a big boost in vaccinations even
though there may be some grousing but as
you know there are cases where police
officers or health workers or pilots are
walking off the job rather than get the
vaccine are you still
full speed ahead on mandates for
essential workers to get vaccinated
we have seen that these mandates are
getting more and more people vaccinated
here's what we know the most disruptive
thing that you can do to a workforce is
to have a covet outbreak in that
workforce that will most definitely not
only send people home but it will send
people to the hospital and some may pass
what we know from the police workforce
is that there have been more deaths from
the coronavirus over the last year and a
half than all other causes of death for
that workforce combined so we believe it
is very important to get these people
vaccinated there is a plan
should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and
counseling to get people the information
they need
did you catch the end there there's a
plan
to get them the education and the
resources they need sort of like a
re-education camp should we maybe put
them in gulags or in special areas
remove them from society where we can
then teach them what is good and right
where they have to bow to the state and
get injected despite whatever legitimate
concerns they may have would that be
good maybe
maybe there would be these camps
that we could build and they would think
that they were walking into a shower to
be cleansed but there would be gas would
that be would that be all right
you see what these people are doing you
see what these people are doing if you
think what i just said there is a little
over the top right is like a little bit
much
look at what has happened in the last
year and a half how far we have fallen
okay so when i say that i don't think
tomorrow she's gassing police officers
but i don't think that it actually would
be too far away when you take a certain
segment of society and say they are the
diseased and they might kill you what do
you think the people in power would do
to them look at history that is exactly
what these people would do she is not a
good person these are not good people i
don't know are they lizard people when
people talk about the lizard people
these are lizard people i guess they're
lizard people i don't know i don't even
know exactly what that means did lizards
come from another planet and then
they've taken over their bodies or is it
some sort of gene splicing with the
lizard thing or something but these are
not good people but you want to see good
people i got some hope for you because
there are good people out there and this
makes me damn proud to originally be a
new yorker because this is what new york
is all about here are new york police
depa police officers and fire department
officers marching across the brooklyn
bridge this is from this morning you
ain't going to see this on cnn today
oh
[Applause]
my god chance of usa
desire for freedom a care for individual
rights the american flag
those are good people okay they don't
want to get anyone sick they just don't
want the government
intruding on their decisions and for the
four billionth time if you believe the
vaccines work then stop pretending that
if someone else doesn't get vaccinated
it has anything to do with you when i am
here in this ridiculous dystopian city
of los angeles and this weekend i did go
to the supermarket i left my house guys
i don't yeah i don't go out off and i
did leave the house
david's out of town so i had to fend for
myself and i bought a piece of salmon
and some broccoli and i went to the
supermarket and
you know i wear my mask beneath my nose
nobody says anything i sort of had it
even even further when i was really
pushing it um but when you look around
at these people nobody's even you could
just see this glossed over look in their
eyes no one why is there no discussion
now about taking masks off it's not even
being discussed at any level
whatsoever here in l.a and i get it
those of you that are watching this in
florida and texas the ship has sailed
you're better people than us i
understand maybe we're on our way who
knows but the point is
uh these people they just want more
thank you sir may i have another they
just want more but those people marching
right right there not only are those the
people that a year ago we were calling
the heroes these are these are
firefighters these are police officers
these are nurses these are the heroes
who have been out there save us now
they're the people who should be fired
and shamed and and have their lives
utterly destroyed for standing up uh for
what they believe in right remember
remember i talked about this the other
day when we were kids we were told to
stand up for what we believe in not be
bullied you know fight for what's right
how can we never hear about any of that
anymore uh quick comment from sally
valley on locals fauci has no heart and
no wrinkles i suspect botox he yeah i
mean the guy's what he's 81 i'll give
him this look he's an evil freak there's
no doubt about that and he probably has
all sorts of blood on his hands and he
likes to have flesh eating
bugs eat the faces of dogs but he does
look pretty good for 81 years old the
guy doesn't have a lot of wrinkles i
will give him that much all right let's
move on to barack obama you may remember
you may remember barack obama he was uh
the two-term president before
orange man and he was this guy who came
in and it was hope and it was change and
it was very exciting and then obviously
if you flash forward to where we're at
now where we live in a systemically
racist patriarchal society and
capitalism is evil and all of these
things uh he failed miserably his his
eight years in the oval office were
obviously a complete disaster uh i will
say this i voted for barack obama twice
now you guys all know about my political
evolution i was a lefty at the time
there's no doubt about it i did vote for
him both times it is worth noting that
the first time that barack obama ran for
president he was against gay marriage so
barack obama is a homophobe he has an
irrational fear of gay people he did not
want two men or two women uh to be able
to engage in the same sort of
relationship that a heterosexual couple
could now i suppose he did you know
evolve a little bit later but you know
the truth is that in his heart he
obviously hates gay people um and here
he is now barack obama who again didn't
solve any of the things that he set out
to do right because if he did then we
would have never got donald trump and
certainly we wouldn't needed joe biden
who was his vp to come in and fix all of
that right if barack obama had actually
accomplished all the wonderful hope and
change that he had promised well now he
is campaigning in this virginia
gubernatorial race
and just listen to him and i would only
add one other thing which is that during
uh the recall here in california obama
cut an ad that was pro newsom that was a
complete fear-mongering scare monger
scare tactic ad we played it on the show
refused to even say larry elder's name
and congratulations it did work here in
california but here's obama and you just
tell me well you well that play it
why is it republicans don't want
you to vote
what what is it that they're so afraid
of
yeah you know it
it
i would assume terry if if they think
they've got better ideas why don't they
just go make the case
[Applause]
tell us your ideas
tell us why you think they're going to
be better tell us how it's going to help
that man get a job or or help that young
person go to college or help that person
get a trade
hey just explain it and if you've got
good ideas
people will flock to your ideas but but
that's not what they try to do instead
you're trying to rig elections
because the truth is people disagree
with your ideas
[Applause]
and when that doesn't work
you start fabricating lies and
conspiracy theories about the last
election
the one you didn't win that's not how
democracy's supposed to work
let me be very very clear about this
barack obama is not a good man i regret
voting for him i think maybe i said that
once before but i completely regret
voting for barack obama i should have
voted for john mccain and i should have
voted for mitt romney and i ain't no
mitt romney fan
but everything he said there is a lie he
is a smug dishonest snake oil salesman
that's what he is first off republicans
don't want you to vote that's what he's
telling you
simply not true republicans want things
like voter id like they have in
virtually every civilized nation on
planet earth that you would show an id
when you vote much like you show an id
when you get on an airplane or perhaps
when you send a fedex package or when
you rent a hotel room or maybe when you
buy cigarettes or purchase a gun or open
a bank account or apply for food stamps
or welfare or when you apply for social
security or unemployment or when you
rent or buy a house
he's
saying that they want to stop you from
voting but all they want to do is secure
our election system make sure that
people who are supposed to be voting are
voting make sure the people who aren't
supposed to be voting aren't or can't
vote twice etc etc so he's absolutely
lying about that then he says that why
don't they make the case why don't they
make the case for their ideas actually
i would say republicans or conservatives
right leading people are making the case
for low taxes getting us out of war all
of the things that trump talked about
low black unemployment let's invest in
some of these communities let's not
nation build let's leave things to the
states now he does make a point um that
they've got to get their message out and
it's like well they do have trouble
getting their message out because you do
have all of the networks against you all
of the mainstream media against you and
you have big tech against you so i will
you know give him that it's like it's
tough to get the message out when you
can't
and he says if you've got good ideas
then good people will flock to you well
again we have a lying media that just
won't let that happen by the way he went
on to say there was another clip that
was actually possibly even more
extraordinary than that endlessly smug
lie like this was the guy that was
supposed to heal us
man awful but there's another clip where
he talks about how the republicans are
only in it for this fake culture war
this fake outrage war and it's like no
that's not true either man you know good
decent people who don't want their
children taught critical race theory
don't want them to be taught to judge
people by the color of their skin that's
what they don't want for their children
it's like that's not fake man you know
making sure that we all have access to
platforms so that we can speak freely is
not fake making sure that just because
you have some conservative or
non-progressive view you're not going to
be booted off everything or have your
job taken away is not fake fighting so
that the government can't inject you
with whatever it wants whenever it wants
no matter how many times it gets all the
information wrong in the first place is
not fake so he's just a liar he's just
dishonest he's a liar i regret voting
for barack obama i apologize to any of
you good mccain romney people out there
back at the time but you know you live
and learn what can you do but if you
think obama is bad
let's move on to the third story because
there's this harris woman
kamala harris and we played some video
of her last week this was the most
inauthentic woman on the face of the
planet again she was polling at zero
that's not white power this is joe biden
when when democrats do this it means
zero when republicans do it it means
white power so i'm doing it you can take
it as you wish uh last week she had us
they had a surprise birthday party for
her she walked into the room and yelled
surprise to them first time that's ever
happened in the history of surprise
parties she then kissed her husband who
was also wearing a mask i mean this
woman is just terrible polling at zero
in her own party when when she dropped
out of the race but then biden put her
in although it's not really bite and
it's whoever's running biden anyway
uh she tweeted out this statement now
think of all the things before i read it
to you before we show it to you think of
all the things that are happening right
now between vaccine mandates inflation
going up gas prices going up supply
chain issues the disaster in afghanistan
that we don't even talk about anymore
china's testing some like supersonic
nuclear missile like there's so many
crazy things happening right now but
here's what vp harris is up to
president biden and i released the first
ever national gender strategy
we believe that advancing gender equity
and equality is fundamental to every
individual's economic security safety
health and ability to exercise their
most basic rights it is also essential
to economic growth and development
democracy and political stability and
the security of nations across the globe
yet no country in the world has achieved
gender equality and we are at an
inflection point the kovit 19 pandemic
has fueled a health crisis an economic
crisis and a caregiving crisis that have
magnified the challenges that women and
girls especially women and girls of
color have long faced it has also
exacerbated a shadow pandemic of
gender-based violence in the united
states and around the world this moment
demands that we build back
better
before i color that with any of my
thoughts we've got a quote here from the
american enterprise institute about
about men and women and equality women
have earned almost 10 million more
college degrees than men since 1982. so
if you only care about women being
educated and having jobs if you think
that's the most important thing for a
woman because i know somehow modern
feminists think that if you're a mother
who has kids and stays at home and cooks
for the kids and keeps a good house and
takes care of everybody and is around
and emotionally available and not
worried about board meetings and things
somehow you're evil and you're
anti-woman uh but if you if you don't
believe that then at least you've got
the 10 million more college degrees than
men since uh 1982
but just to add a couple of my thoughts
on this um it's nonsense it's complete
nonsense um there are countries you know
one of the struggles years ago i've told
the story a few times but when jordan
and i jordan peterson and i were on tour
we went to sweden and we were going to
do one show in sweden and the show sold
out literally in two minutes so we
thought there's something going on here
and i was getting so much fan mail from
sweden we thought there's something else
happening here let's see if we can get
back to sweden so i think we went to
denmark for a day maybe we went to oslo
and then we went back to
stockholm to sweden
the second show sold out in in about two
minutes and it was just extraordinary
what was going on there and we talked to
a bunch of the audience we did a q a it
was actually uh during my meet and greet
that instead of doing it at the theater
there were so many people that wanted to
be part of my meet and greet we actually
went to a bar we took over the entire
bar it was it was maybe the best night
of the whole tour
sweden
has complete gender equality they have a
completely egalitarian society and
forever men can do whatever they want
women can do whatever they want and
guess what's happened in sweden it's
still despite saying everybody do
whatever the hell you want which is
pretty much what we have here in the
united states too
but they really have it there
in terms of culture and everything else
it turns out that still men wanted to
become engineers and women still wanted
to become nurses because generally men
care about things that's the way men's
brains are wired and women care more
about interpersonal relationships so
that's the way their brains are wired so
now the social justice warriors in
sweden they look at that and they go
wait we have equality but we did it
right like we did what they wanted we
have this egalitarian society we did it
right but the outcome is still that men
and women are doing different things we
don't have the exact amount of male and
female engineers we don't know the exact
amount of male and female nurses so they
want to rejigger the entire system do
you see how ridiculous this all is
anyway the idea that we'd be worried
about that about any of this nonsense if
you showed me a law that said women
can't do this
because they're women then so be it you
know what women can't do uh apparently
women can't be four-star generals
because you know uh what's her name
i forgot her name who's what's her name
again
rachel levine rachel levine yeah rachel
levine so rachel levine was a man i
don't mean to be a dick about it
[Laughter]
so
there was a guy
anyway he's a woman now he's was he's
now the first four-star female general
according to the new york times except
he's not female i i don't want to get my
channel deleted and i'm not trying to
say anything controversial here he's a
trans woman i i accept that sh or she's
a trans woman but she is not female
google female here can we google female
can you google female for me right now
and i'm going to read the official
uh definition of female for those of you
that are completely curious
female
is of or denoting the sex that can bear
offspring or produce eggs distinguished
biologically by the production of ova
which can be fertilized by male gametes
i i don't think rachel levine has that
stuff so i'm not making a big deal about
it and it's just fine that this trans
person's got a gig and it's all good
except she
he she whatever is not female that's not
i'm not trying to be controversial here
but anyway you see why i link this to
they want gender equity except the
four-star general that's the health
secretary whatever it is is biologically
male and you've got the feminists going
oh my god we've got the first female oh
my god i'm a seal throw me more fish
okay if all of that we got one more for
you today if all of that is not enough
everyone in this administration is just
an absolutely ridiculous partisan moon
okay they really really are i'm trying
to be nice today for god's sakes it's
monday had a good weekend like i'm
trying but these people are just insane
so uh treasury secretary janet yellen
is saying that in order to pay for
buildback better uh that she's got a
very special way of doing it and it's
not exactly a wealth tax but
well um i think what's under
consideration is a proposal that
senator wyden and the senate finance
committee have been looking at that
would
impose
a tax on unrealized capital gains
on liquid assets held by extremely
wealthy individuals billionaires
i wouldn't call that a wealth tax but
it would help get at
capital gains which
are an extraordinarily large part of the
incomes of the wealthiest individuals
and
right now
escape taxation
until they're realized and often they're
unrealized and that death
benefit from a so-called step up of
basis so it's not a wealth tax but um
attacks on unrealized capital gains of
exceptionally wealthy individuals
my sharpie's running out of ink from
writing down so many stupid things from
that woman so first off
the key part of this
she wants to impose a tax on
unrealized capital gains
unrealized that means capital gains that
don't exist now without getting too far
into the nitty-gritty of all of this
capital gains for those of you that
don't know are a profit from the sale of
a property or investment so if you make
a ton of money on an investment or on a
property there's a capital gains tax on
that that is the capital gains and you
pay an extra tax on that what she's
saying is they want to tax unrelated
capital gains so meaning if you make a
really good investment on a house let's
say let's say you buy a house for 300
grand right and then and you picked a
great spot in a great location and you
did your due diligence and it's a great
investment and you put work into it and
all that stuff and next thing you know
two years later it's worth 550 grand
but you don't want to sell well now
you've increased your the value of that
house by 250 grand she wants to tax that
she says this is about billionaires but
of course it's not just about
billionaires of course it isn't they
want to tax unrealized gains so it's not
that they just want to punish you for
success they want to protect punish you
for potential success and on top of
everything else imagine thinking that
that needs more of your money
these people don't deserve any more of
your money they just don't unrealized
capital gains incredible oh and of
course the point is that she's talking
about her build back better thing and
all that these are the same people who
just told us that 3.5 trillion dollars
equals zero because we're going to tax
those people and of course that's a lie
3.5 trillion doesn't equal zero if you
borrow ten dollars from someone it isn't
borrowing zero just because you say it
is right um it's just absolutely
extraordinary and it's also class
warfare of the worst kind i'm not saying
that every one of our laws is just but
but don't hate the player hate the game
then you can change some of the laws i
suppose if you want but the idea that
we're demonized billionaires and people
that have money for playing the game you
know it's like when they would always go
after trump for all of these things with
taxes and he'd be writing off losses and
all of these things it's like yeah
that's how it works and if you don't
like that change the laws but they don't
want to do that they do they just want
to demonize people it's just absolutely
ridiculous
oh wait what was the last thing there
oh because she said these people are
escaping taxation until they are
realized
realized so that means that if you do
something good if you're a smart
investor
if you know how to play the game if
you're wise when it comes to real estate
or whatever it is you do with your money
you're escaping them so they better get
you this is pre-crime this is minority
report kind of okay these people
are completely
completely out of control
on that note
i feel very good about this monday show
i feel it was a solid show
uh tomorrow we are announcing something
massive uh we actually may do an early
live stream tomorrow i think for this
announcement so it sounds like at seven
a.m pacific 10 a.m uh eastern we will be
live with this announcement because i
want you guys to hear it from me first
because it is gonna break across the
news it is it is big stuff we'll do a
regular show at 11 o'clock but uh i
think we're going to confirm in just a
sec that i will be live at 7am tomorrow
and it's big and you guys have all been
uh a part of it whether you knew it or
not uh my full interview uh with
congresswoman lauren bobert is up right
now on the youtube part one of my
interview with brian keating really
interesting the guy just wrote a really
really fantastic book about science and
how we can look at science and how
science is not just
about
one plus one equals two it's there's
there's creativity in science we have to
think about things differently and
really what damage our public scientists
community has done to scientists uh done
to science overall uh and to some
scientists i should say uh so you can
check out part one right now on youtube
the full episode's already up at
reubenreport.locals.com it is a big week
that's all i got for you i hope you
enjoy the show have a great day i'll see
you tomorrow
you